And our feature presenter today,
is Professor Bernie Roth.
Bernie is the Rodney H Adams, professor
of engineering at Stanford University.
He earned his PhD in Mechanical
Engineering from Columbia University.
And has honorary PhD's from the University
of Paris, and the University of Cassino.
He has published widely in
the areas of design, creativity,
education, kinematics, and robotics.
And has many awards for
both his teaching and research.
He has served as a director for several
corporations and has held top leadership
positions in several international
professional societies.
He is also a co-founder of Stanford's
d.school where he now serves as
the Academic Director.
And his latest book,
The Achievement Habit,
was published in July
2015 by HarperCollins.
And now I'd like to turn
the floor over to Bernie.
>> Hello, everybody, thanks for
joining in.
And I would say good morning or good
afternoon, but it depends where you are.
So whatever it is, good to you.
I just want to start off by
saying something about the title.
And the title has the word
success in it and achieve in it.
And I used these words in
a kind of unusual way in that
most people think success means becoming
emperor or empress of the universe.
What I mean by them is that
you have a good life and
that you feel good about yourself and
people feel good about you.
And basically when you die, friends
that eulogize you don't have to lie.
You can define what all that means for
you personally.
But the main thing we're
going to talk about is problems.
And I think it's important to understand
something about what I mean by problems.
And for me, problems are a life force.
It's actually what makes us tick.
There's actually a story I like very
much that's a novel written in the 1860s
in Russia, in Czarist Russia.
And the main character's name is Oblomov,
and that's the title of the book.
And for
the first 200 some odd pages of the book,
the main character never leaves his bed.
And it's because he's
a very wealthy person and
everyone takes care of everything for him.
And the idea is that if
you have no problems,
you have nothing to do,
why get out of bed?
And of course the book is
just a critical statement
about the life of the aristocracy
in czarist Russia.
But I think it's a really important point.
I find that when I have problems,
have things I'm concerned about doing,
it's an exciting part of my life.
It's kind of what makes me tick.
And I think we all do it that way,
we may or
may not think of it that way
consciously but it's important.
So for me the problem with the word
problems is that it sounds bad.
When, in fact, it's good.
So I think that if you understand that,
the kind of people around me who
are big on entrepreneurship and all that,
they say problems are opportunities.
And the bigger the problem,
the bigger the opportunity.
Now that may be an extreme view for
you, but it is actually true that
solving problems is a pleasure and it's
actually necessary to get along in life.
Now most of us do a good job at it and
occasionally we get stumped and I'm going
to talk to you about what happens when
we get stumped a little later on.
But first I want to talk to you
about successful problem solving for
others because it's easy if
we look at how we do it for
others to understand what we don't
do right when we do for ourselves.
So one of the things we do
when we solve problems for
others is we come up
with a problem statement.
I prefer using the word point of view,
rather than a problem statement,
because it implies that in fact the thing
that we're working on is subjective.
It's not an objective reality.
So we say problem statement.
Implies more something
that's objectively given.
In fact, all the time there's
a subjective view to it.
And the way we do it is we get
a phrase describing a specific user,
which is a very important point.
Who we're solving the problem for.
That a phrase specifying a need and then a
phrase giving an insight specifying what,
but not how the solution
needs to accomplish.
And I'll give you a specific example
that's to make it more concrete.
So in a course I taught,
the students came up with a problem
statement which was Maria,
a poor single mother, needs financial know
how so she can use her money efficiently.
Now if you look at that statement,
Maria's what it's about, there's a need,
financial know how, and what it would
accomplish would be to get her money,
get her to use her money efficiently.
So that's kind of the framing of it.
And when you see that, you can see there
is an insight implied in in here and
that is if she gets more knowledge she's
going to do better with some money.
Now that's an assumption.
And it may not be true.
She may be spendthrift as she may know
everything there is to know about money
and still not do well about it.
So you have this assumption, and
you have to test it if you're
going to solve the problem.
In this case, the students worked
with some janitors at Stanford.
And they tested their insight.
And they found that giving some,
a small amount of knowledge,
changed these people's lives.
That this woman was able to save $1400 in
six months on a salary
of less than $40,000.
So she was saving 9% of her income,
which she had never done before.
But by virtue of them getting
her access to banking,
by virtue of them giving her some
knowledge, and things like that.
So that was, in fact,
a life-changing thing, both for the people
that the problem was solved for and also
for the people who solved the problem,
because they went and
made a company based on that insight.
And the company did very well.
It's won all sorts of awards.
And basically what the company
does it ties people
to financial institutions using
a cell phone, not a smartphone,
just an ordinary cell phone, and
speaks to them in their own language.
And it's been so successful that
the company is called Juntos,
which in Spanish means together.
And now they're in 12 countries
across 4 continents dealing with
some of the biggest banks in the world.
So this is just an example of how
if you have the right problem,
sort of magic can happen if you pursue it.
And that's kind of the point of what I'm
going to talk about to you, yourself and
your own personal life.
And the so question that we're
really concern about is not so
much what was done in classes and
the more formal methods we used in
what we called design thinking.
But problem solving for yourself,
applying the same ideas and techniques.
And so what are we going to do?
How come, do you ever think of this?
I haven't met you, but
I know you're intelligent.
You're intelligent enough to sign up for
this webinar,
so that shows you're
a highly intelligent person.
And how come people like you, and
people that I work with every day,
and I, myself, and
people in my family, and
my friends we get stuck and
we lose sleep over simple problems?
They're not like rocket
science problems as we say.
And they're not generally, things like
peace in the world forever and you know.
Global issues.
We generally lose sleep over very
small problems which have to do
with our relationships with our families,
with our work,
with the small everyday
issues of our lives.
How come, you've solve harder problems?
Everyone I work with has
solved harder problems.
How come you're stuck
with problems like that?
And I've talked to thousands
of people over the years, and
everyone really has problems
that they lose sleep over.
I only met one person actually,
who claims he didn't have
any problems falling asleep.
He happens to be the youngest mayor
of the city of Stockton right now.
I haven't checked with him recently, but
I'm sure he's losing sleep over something.
So I think it's universal.
So what can go wrong?
In most cases,
what goes wrong is you're using an old
answer instead of a new question.
You think you're dealing
with the question, but
you're dealing with an answer.
I'll give you a simple example of
that that happened in my life.
It's a very trivial example, but
it makes the point very nicely.
I had a friend visiting me and I wanted
to take him up to the wine country and
I didn't have a car available,
so I rented a car.
We spent a nice time and eventually,
we're running out of gasoline,
so we went to gas station.
At that point, the drama started,
I went to look for
the button that releases
the cover on the gas tank.
I looked every place I have ever had
one in any car I've ever been and
I couldn't find it.
And then I took out the manual in
the glove compartment to see if I could
find it and then suddenly,
a miracle happened.
A car of a similar make drove up,
similar make, similar model.
So I ran up to the woman and I said,
this is a stupid question but
can you tell me where the button is
to open the cover on the gas tank?
And she said there is none.
I could have just going to over and
opened the cover and
it would not have been a problem.
Mainly, it's trivial, I wasted ten
minutes of my life, it's no big deal but
it does show what happened.
I had the old answer, which is find the
button in order to get to the gas tank.
The new question was how
do I open the cover?
So I was really working
on the wrong problem and
that's exactly what
happens a lot of times.
Let's talk a little bit more about it.
If you look at something like
bike riding as an analogy,
most people think they know
the rules of bike riding.
But if you're going to ride
bikes at a higher level,
there are rules which at
first seem counter-intuitive.
For example, if you ride a bike
really well, you're not using your
handlebars to steer the bike, you're
using your body weight to steer the bike.
You don't sit on the seat if you want to
win the race, I got news for you.
If you watch races,
they're not sitting on the seat and
you're certainly not pushing on
the pedals, I'll tell you that much.
People have clips and they're pulling and
it's coming out of the rest of your body,
not the foot part,
it's the forces coming from within you.
So these are three rules which in
bike riding seem counter-intuitive
if you're an amateur.
I want to do the same thing
to you in problem solving.
I want to give you a set of three rules
which are really important rules if you're
going to solve problems at a better level
then you've been doing it up till now.
my three rules are,
don't use answers as questions,
I'll explain these in greater detail.
That's what the talk will be about.
Don't use answers as
questions is the first rule.
Don't use reasons is the second rule.
And don't confuse trying with doing.
So those to me are the three
primary rules of
trying to solve problems
at a higher level.
And I'll now explain to you in
some detail what I mean by these.
If you're stuck, really,
if you're literally stuck, the chances
are very strong you're treating
a wrong answer as a right question.
And that's universally true,
I've found that in my consulting work,
I've found that in working
with PhD students.
I find that in work with my family,
I find that in my job,
I find that everywhere in my life,
that that's what happens.
So the question is,
how do you get unstuck if you're stuck?
If you got the gum under your shoe,
how do you get rid of it?
As I say, the rule is don't
use answers as questions.
What do I mean by that?
Here's something that happened.
This is a true story of I was working
with a large group of people,
and I asked them,
what are you losing sleep over?
And this one woman said,
I really can't find a spouse.
I've tried everything,
I've gone on the Internet and
all that stuff, she was stuck.
So, the way I would unstuck her is,
I would say what would it do for
you if you solved your problem?
What is this the answer to?
This is the answer to some problem.
What is finding a spouse the answer to?
Or the way I said it to her is, what would
it do for you if you found a spouse?
She said, I'd have companionship.
So what happens then is we've gone to
getting companionship is really
the question she wants to work out.
So the question is how does
she get companionship?
Once she does that and forgets for
the moment about finding a spouse,
the solution space opens up tremendously.
Because how might I find a companion
has in addition to finding a spouse,
meet friends online, take classes,
get a pet, join a club, go to jail, etc.
So you can get companionship in lots and
lots of ways.
So what's happened by reframing the
problem is you've opened up the solution
space and that's one of the magic
that's very important to understand.
Now to do that,
you have to be willing to let go of
the original finding a spouse idea.
Now it's ironic because of I've
been married for a very long time,
and one of the big issues in my life,
in my marriage, is companionship.
because I'm busy talking to you on
the webinar and I'm doing a lot of other
things, and I'm not giving my wife
as much companionship as I like.
Since we've been married for over 60
years, I don't think she'll divorce me but
it's an issue.
So the idea is if this
woman found a spouse,
he might not give her companionship,
he might be even worse than me.
So she wouldn't be really
solving her problem, so
what she's done is she's
taking an old answer,
which is get a spouse, for a new question,
which is really finding companionship.
And if she reframes it,
it opens up and in fact,
she might do better finding a spouse if
she wasn't so needy for companionship.
So that's the basic idea.
I'll give you an amusing version of
it which came up in a workshop I did,
which I liked very much.
This woman had the problem that her
boyfriend was snoring a lot and
she just couldn't handle it.
They went to doctors, they had a surgery.
They did all sorts of medical things and
nothing worked.
So again, I said, what would it do for
you if your boyfriend stopped snoring?
And she said,
I'd be able to get a good night's sleep.
Now the problem she should be
working on Is a good night's sleep,
forget about stopping snoring.
And if you open it up and say, how do I
get a good night's sleep, there's many
possibilities, including changing the
boyfriend, [LAUGH] which is a good one.
Or sleep in the other room or
earplugs, and
so forth and so on, so the poor guy
could snore, and you could sleep.
So it's again, it's this whole idea
of trying to solve the wrong problem.
And even if he stopped snoring, maybe she
still wouldn't get a good night's sleep.
Maybe he'd bother her in other ways,
I don't know.
So the point simply is, if you know what
do we really want to be after make sure
that's what you working on.
Now this thing it's, and what happens is,
I hate to do this with Stanford freshmen.
Because they say, but
then I didn't get a spouse.
But I didn't stop snoring.
They won't let go of the original problem.
And it's a freshman syndrome, okay?
Because once you're a graduate student and
you realize in life it's much better
to disappear problems than solve it.
If you disappear your problem,
it's gone forever.
Whereas if you solve it,
it can come back and haunt you.
So it's really interesting.
It's okay to let go of
the original thing and
not just cling to it because
that's what you chose originally.
Okay, so in my case, I never found
the button to open that gas tank.
I never found that button.
But I'm sleeping very nicely,
because I had a full tank of gas and
went on with my life.
And that's analogous to everything.
You have to be willing to
let go of the wrong thing,
which was an answer to
the wrong problem all right.
Now I'll give you some really powerful
examples of this is a project
that some students did.
It had to do with premature children.
So, when a baby is born prematurely,
it must stay warm or it will die.
It cannot manufacture
enough heat by itself.
You need to do it externally and
the say it's done in most of the world
is with things called incubators.
We have these at the Stanford Hospital.
You have them almost universally in
places where people have hospice.
And a group of doctors
came to us from Nepal and
they said look we have these incubators,
they're donated, they cost $20,000.
They're donated from India but
we have some problems.
One problem is they keep breaking and
we can't repair them.
And the other is that you need
electricity, if there's no electricity,
there's no warmth and the baby dies.
And in Nepal the electricity
is intermittent at best.
So, the problem they gave us, well,
could you keep fixed the incubators and
make sure they work.
So, before the students went to Nepal
they work on battery backups to keep
the electricity going.
And to redesign it with fewer
parts to make it simpler.
And then they went to Nepal and
they were horrified because they found out
that the incubators are in the clinics.
The clinics are in the villages,
in the towns.
Many of the mothers are up in the hills,
they can't get there in
time even if these worked.
Even if these incubators were perfect and
they worked,
the mothers can't leave their other
children alone, they let the baby die.
They just can't get there in time.
A lot of things indicated that this
was the wrong thing to be working on.
Okay?
So they reframed it, and they
understood they needed a point of view
which took care of the mother and
the child.
The question was, the mother and
the child were the user,
the need was to keep the baby alive.
And so they invented something that
looks like, well, you could just say
the problem here in terms of reframing
it is make the machine work.
That's the wrong problem,
the idea is to save the children.
So if you save the children,
you can do other things.
They came up with something which looks
like a sleeping bag and the magic is that
is has inside of it a bladder which is
made of a kind of wax like material which
when you heat it, it melts and it
absorbs a lot of heat and it takes about
5 hours to give off the heat, and it
keeps the baby at the right temperature.
And you could melt it with anything,
you don't need electricity.
You could use electricity, but you could
boil water, you could use the sun.
So you melt the wax anyway you can,
and you're not relying on electricity.
And it's saved over 300,000
babies at this point,
and there was a nice moment when they
were invited to the old White House and
this gentleman was nice enough
to say nice things about it.
So it's an example of reframing
the problem to the right problem.
In this case,
it wasn't fix the incubators.
It was keep the babies alive.
And another one, which is also
a classic one, has to do with someone,
a friend of ours,
who works at General Electric.
His name is Doug Dietz and he designs
MRI machines for children, he designed
at one point, and what happened is he
designed the machine you can see there.
And he went into a clinic
to see how it's going and
he was told they loved his machine.
The nurses loved his machine and then he
was so horrified to find out that about
85% of the children have to be sedated
before they can go into the machine.
They're so terrified by the machine.
And he never saw the machine
from the point of a child.
Where you're sort of asked to crawl
into the mouth of a metal monster.
And he realized that really,
he ought to talk to some children.
So he went around talking to children that
were chronic patients and all that, and
when he found that when he talked to some,
one child that was cancer patient
that her life was sort of devoid of
any adventure or any excitement,
that her brother have who was well
you know have all these trophies and
she had sort of a very spared life
because of her medical issues.
And he figured well what you really
need in life is excitement and
adventure and all that.
So what he did is he didn't touch the
machines he just repainted them basically.
And they made the machines as
part of an adventure series.
So the top right one shows a pirate
ship and you have to hold still so
the pirates don't find you.
And the other one is on the water and
what he did is, before the children came,
they made a comic book showing rays going
through your body, where you see bones.
And they got nap sacks for the children.
So they made it an adventure
rather than a medical experience.
And the sedation rate dropped
down from 8.5% to about 1%.
And she children were heard saying
mommy can we come back tomorrow.
So what happened is he
reframed the problem again
from one of does the machine work.
Which it didn't because the children
were getting sedated all that.
To one where not only to save them but
to give them an adventure,
to give them something delightful.
And he found that need by saying,
what was he really trying to do?
So that's the idea, so
that's kind of rule one.
Make sure you're working
on the right problem.
Most of us solve problems all the time.
We're always working on the right
problems, except when we're not.
And when we're not, those
are the problems we're losing sleep over.
And those are the problems to reframe.
So if you're just going along your
life and you're solving problems, and
everything is great, don't worry about.
You don't need anything I've said.
Forget about it.
On the other hand, if you're losing
sleep and things are bad, and
you don't know what to do, give it a shot.
Reframe the problem.
And simply the way to
reframe it is really simple.
Just say what would it do for
me if I solve the problem?
That will give you a new problem.
Work on that new problem,
forget about the original one.
It's magic,
it really works very very well, but
you have to be big enough not to
hang onto the original problem, and
you have to be big enough
not to lie to yourself.
The problem is most of us lie to
ourselves, we have a certain self-image,
and we don´t tell ourselves the truth,
why we want to solve this problem.
So you have to be truthful about what it
is you want to get out of the problem.
And if you do that then you´re
going to do the right thing.
So if this woman just said companionship.
Because she just made that up and she
didn't want to tell me some other nastier
reason she wants to get married like she
wants a rich guy to take care of her or
whatever it is, it's not going to help.
But if you tell yourself the truth then it
will help and you will often the solutions
will be right out there in front of
you and often it almost solves itself.
So that is the first rule.
The 2nd rule is reasons.
Did you ever ask yourself what's
the purpose of reasons in the world?
Why do we have reasons?
Well I've asked myself that and
I've thought about it a lot.
And I've come up with
the following answer.
The only use of reasons is
to seem to be reasonable.
That's the only use of reasons is
to seem to be a reasonable person.
So, for example if I did something.
If I went over and I,
to some arbitrary person on the street and
I kick them, and they said well,
why did you do that?
I say I don't know,
I'm not a reasonable person.
But if I'd kicked him and I said,
you reminded me of that kid in the fifth
grade who used to bully me, then I have
a good reason for kicking him, right?
So I'm a reasonable person.
So that's absurd.
But in general,
that's the level for most reasons.
They're really not useful.
But, and
who cares whether they can be harmful and
that's the point about that so
I'll say a lot more about that right now.
The first thing to understand is there's
no one reason for any human behavior.
We are very complicated people and
whatever we do takes into account our
history, our connection to other people,
our connections to our friends, and
it's not just the thing itself, so
if someone asks me, Bernie will you
do me a favor and do something?
I might say yes, and
if you say well why'd you do that?
I say, well he asked me to do it.
But if a different person asks me I might
say no, with all the same circumstances.
Because of my history with the person.
So our lives are very complicated, we go
way back in the past in terms of our DNA,
and how we do things never
is one specific thing.
So what happens, is if someone asks
you a reason, or you need a reason for
yourself, you'll pick the one
reason that makes you look good.
You'll pick the one reason
that makes you look okay.
So for example, whenever I give this talk,
at this point I notice my mouth is dry,
which it is at this moment, okay?
And if you say to me, well,
why is your mouth dry?
I'll say, well, I've been talking a lot.
That seems reasonable, right?
But I don't tell you that last night
I had a bottle of wine for dinner.
I don't tell you that I'm
always chronically dehydrated.
My wife says I never drink enough.
So I don't tell you all of those other
things in my history which would lead
to me not necessarily having a dry
mouth even if I talked a lot.
Okay?
So what I do is I take the one
simple thing in this very
complicated set of things.
I don't know the reason my mouth is dry.
It just is dry, okay?
And all these things are true
that I just said to you, and
a few others I don't want to
tell you contribute to it.
So I pick the one,
which is I'm talking a lot.
Fine.
And that's reasonable.
And who cares?
The problem with that is
often reasons are an excuse.
And if you use them as excuses,
they don't let you accomplish
what you want to accomplish.
And by using the reason,
you let yourself off the hook.
My epiphany on this many years ago, I was
on the board of directors of a company in
Berkeley and I would periodically go to
the board meeting by driving from
Stanford, Palo Alto on the freeway
to Berkeley to the meeting off
the Berkeley campus somewhere.
And I was always late I
was late in every meeting.
And when I came in I said there was
a large traffic on the highway.
I came in I said, gee,
I'm really sorry I'm late.
There's so much traffic on
those days it was highway 17.
So much traffic on Highway 17.
And they say, it's okay, Bernie,
as long as nothing happened.
But then I realized it wasn't okay
because these people have lives too, and
I was being abusive, and
I was keeping them waiting.
And at one point I realized that I
should either get there on time,
or I should leave the board.
And I realized in a way that my
behavior was insulting to them because
I wasn't giving them
enough valance in my life.
I wasn't giving them enough,
it wasn't important.
What was important was the last few phone
calls I took before there was no cell
phones those days.
The last few phone calls I took
in my office before I left.
The teletype message I had to send out,
the conversation I had with
a colleague in the hall.
And by the time I got to my car,
if there was no traffic in Palo Alto,
no traffic on the highway, no traffic
in Berkeley, I would have made it.
But there was traffic,
so I didn't make it.
And I blamed the traffic.
But of course, the realization was
I was not leaving early enough.
I wasn't giving it enough
valence as I say in my life.
Once I had that, I changed my life from
becoming the person who was always late
for everything, to the pain, the backside
that starts everything on time,
that's always on time, and is never late.
And it's really simple.
It makes my life so
much simple in terms of driving.
I don't have to do near death experiences
that come only five minutes late and
stuff of that nature.
And this is simply that once I was
willing to tell myself the truth and
not say it's the traffic,
I could handle it.
It's simple as that.
So that's a really important
thing to understand.
And basically I think that the best
position to have is that reasons are ****.
All reasons are basically ****.
Even if you don't intend them to be
that way because you don't know.
I mean the people put subjects
into MRI machines, and
they've had them dictate an action,
and then give a reason for the action.
And it turns out the parts
of the brain that fires
first is the one that does the action.
The part that comes up
with the reason is after.
So basically you do what you do, and
then you make up a reason for it.
Most of the time you're in automatic,
most of it.
You don't think about walking,
you don't think about breathing,
you don't think about talking.
You just talk, it comes out.
So then you say, why'd you say that?
Then I'll think up a reason why I said it,
I just said it.
I don't know why I said it,
and it's the same thing.
You don't know the reasons for
these things and
it's supposed to be reasonable
to have a reason for everything.
But it doesn't work that way.
I don't know if you've had this
experience, I've had it many times.
I'd make up my mind to do something and
then suddenly I'm doing something else.
You know all the time.
Like people make up
they're going to die and
then they're eating candy or
they do this and they do wrong.
So you're not in control,
I got news for you.
There's something very
complicated controlling so
the reasons are just to cover for
being out of control basically.
So basically, if you just keep
the idea that reasons are ****,
it's really an important thing.
So, it's better to keep
silence than add ****.
You don't need the reasons.
You often do not,
no one cares what the reasons are.
It's a question of what you did or what
you didn't do, not what the reason is.
The reason's irrelevant.
Okay?
So the main thing is do
not try this at home.
I am just fearful that
you're going to go home and
tell everyone in your life their
reasons are ****, that doesn't work.
I've never once told my wife her reasons
are ****, I've never once told my
children their reasons are ****, I've
never once told my biking buddies their
reasons are ****, I've never once told
anyone I work with their reasons are ****.
It's the best way possible
to ruin a relationship.
But the person you can tell is yourself.
And it's really important to tell
yourself that way and to just know that.
And if you say something,
you realize it's ****, It's okay but
you say to yourself,
I'm never going to do that again.
And you'll do it again but
eventually you'll stop.
Whereas if you just keep doing it and
don't notice it, you'll never stop.
So if you want to change your behavior,
if you want to improve, just keep in mind
that the reason you just said it, even
with the best of intentions, is pure ****.
So don't give reasons
unless you have to and
don't be a jerk if someone says what's
the reason for this, tell them something.
Okay?
But if you can, do not give reasons.
I have this experience
where I get maybe four or
five emails a month from students in,
nowadays, it's China or
Iran or Pakistan, who want to come
to Stanford to do a PhD with me.
And some of them are really well thought
out messages and they've researched me and
all that and I could ignore them.
I don't owe them anything but
I felt uncomfortable.
So what I used to do is give them some
good reason, I can't do it, some excuse.
I'm sorry, I don't have any money.
Or I'm going on sabbatical.
And whenever I gave them a reason,
they pushed back.
So if I don't have any money,
they say I have a rich uncle.
If I'm going on sabbatical,
I can wait for you, professor.
And then we go on and
on until I just truncate it and
I had a bad feeling about it.
Now that I have this epiphany about
reasons, I don't give them reasons.
I get the email, I say, sorry,
can't help you, good luck.
And what happens is about 90% of the time,
get back an email saying, thank you for
answering my email, professor.
It's the end of the story.
It's such a good example.
They don't need a reason.
They just want to know,
are you going to let me in or you're not.
Once they know, it's over.
The drama is over.
They'll move on [INAUDIBLE].
And it's really important
to keep that in mind.
Do not use reasons unless
you really have to, okay?
So that's the second rule, okay?
And it's really important.
We have a kind of funny thing.
We have a thing, people I work with,
we all know this idea,
if someone gives you reason, for
example, we have some faculty member
who'll get up in a meeting and say,
well, the reason I can't do it is
that the dean said blah, blah, blah.
That's a good reason with a lot
of o's in there, like five or
six o's, meaning it's ****.
So the code for
us is we just say that's a good reason.
And you can do that for
yourself, it really helps.
If you give yourself a reason for
something you have,
just tell yourself that's a good reason.
And you'll get a lot of insight
because it's ****, okay.
And finally, we come to the third rule,
which is not to confuse trying with doing,
okay, and
that's kind of an interesting thing.
Now, if you're a fan of Star Wars,
you're quivering at this point because
you don't know that Yoda was wrong.
I always prove at this point, I'm afraid
I'm going to be struck dead, but So
far I've gotten away with it.
There is a try, there is a try.
I know what they were saying in the movie,
I have no problem with that but
in real life there is a try and
there's nothing wrong with trying.
Trying is okay, it's just not doing.
It's just something else,
it's another activity which is good and
there are all sorts of different
activities which are okay,
one of which is called doing and it's
important not to confuse all these other
things Which looked like it was doing and
let me explain that to you.
So to do you need to have an intention, so
first well what is your intention, okay?
If you don't have any intention
it's just a pipe dream.
Pipe dream refers to people who
used to smoke opium in dens and.
Smoke a pipe with opium and dreamt
about all sorts of wonderful things.
So we all have wonderful dreams.
We all have pipe dreams.
There's nothing wrong with it.
Pipe dreams are wonderful,
even if you don't have opium.
It's wonderful to have pipe dreams.
You have dreams whatever they are.
It's great to have all sorts of fantasies.
There's nothing wrong with it.
But that's not your intention.
That's just a dream.
Okay this one.
And if you have something that you
really have intention of doing,
are you willing to give it attention?
So you need these two things,
you need to have intention and
you need to have attention.
So if you have an intention
to do something,
it's not going to happen
unless you give it attention.
Attention it requires.
There is a word that not many people
know even if you are a native speaker,
it is called VELLEITY and a lot of people
experience velleity, now what velleity
means is is the least possible effort
you can possibly put into something.
So you have a real good idea,
I am going to start business.
And I'll think about it for a while and
maybe I'll do something tomorrow,
that's velleity.
Velleity is just,
it's one step beyond the pipe dream.
You slither, going to implement, but it's
a little too much to get out of bed, or
two much work.
So that's velleity, all right?
So that's no attention, if you have
velleity, you don't have attention.
So I think you could make a little chart,
which I made for you to see.
And on one axis, under the vertical axis,
I plot intention.
The horizontal axis, I plot attention.
And we can talk about
four states of being.
The lover left state is a pipe dream,
where you have very little attention and
very little intention.
So it's something you just dream about.
You have no intention or attention.
If you go up on the left hand side to the
top one, you have something where you have
an intention But there's no
attention being given to it, that's.
You have an intention to do it, but
you don't give it any attention.
And then on the right hand side on
the bottom, you have what's called trying.
Trying is when you have
an intention to do something.
And you give it a little attention.
You give it a little attention.
And it might work.
It might work.
It might be simple.
And it's fine.
It'll happen.
It might happen.
On the other hand,
if it requires a lot more attention, or
you encounter an obstacle or
something, you don't do it.
It doesn't happen.
And then finally on the top quadrant
on the right, we have doing.
Doing requires both intention and
attention.
You have to intend to do it and you have
to give it the attention it requires.
Now all four states,
as far as I'm concerned, are fine.
There's nothing wrong with pipe dreams,
there's nothing wrong with velleity,
there's nothing wrong with trying,
there's nothing wrong with doing.
It could even be better to try.
I'll give you an example
that happened in my life.
My wife hates when I tell the story but
I think it's perfect and
she's not listening so I'll tell you.
We were coming home from San Francisco and
we passed a movie theatre called the Roxy
which is a kind of funky theater
in the Mission District that shows
movies you don't see anywhere else.
And I noticed the line around the rock
was bigger than I'd ever seen,
it was going around the block.
And I realized it was a movie about
a musical group and the group was there.
I had never heard of them.
But clearly,
all these people there must be great.
So I say to my wife,
let's go to the movies.
She said, no, I'm tired, let's go home.
I said, come on, let's go to the movies.
She finally relented.
She said, okay, let's go.
I said, okay, jump out of the car, buy the
tickets, I'll go find the parking space.
Ten minutes later, I come back and
my wife is not in line.
She's just standing in
front of the ticket booth.
I said, well, how come you're not in line?
She said, they're sold out.
I said, well, how come you're not online?
She said, didn't you hear me?
They're sold out.
I said, yeah, but you stay here.
And I went along the line, and
I got two tickets somehow.
And we went to the show.
And it's a great example,
when my wife was trying So
I'd say awareness or
mindfulness is the key.
It's a good reason, they're sold out.
It's a good reason not to go, right, so.
I was doing, didn't matter, sold out or
not, I was going to get those tickets,
come hell or high water, I was doing.
Now it turns out in this
case it was terrible.
Trying would have been
much better than doing.
[LAUGH] You never know.
Sometimes you can get killed doing.
So I'm not voting, I'm not voting.
And really in life, sometimes, it's
really fun to try and it doesn't happen.
But it's a difference between trying and
doing, you understand that?
I have an example where I was supposed to
go to a meeting that I didn't want to go
to, I was sort of obligated to go to it.
It was in Dallas, Fort Worth, and
I came to the San Francisco airport,
and it was a miracle.
All the flights to Dallas, Fort Worth were
cancelled because there was a snow storm.
So I called up the people, I said I'm
sorry, I can't come, it's snowing.
They said, we understand,
thanks, and all that.
Now the truth is, if I wanted to,
if my life depended on getting to Dallas,
Fort Worth, snow storm or not, airport
closed or not, I would have gotten there.
So I'd say awareness or
mindfulness is the key.
It didn't happen, it was great, it was the
best thing in the world that I was trying.
But if I was doing,
it wouldn't have stopped me.
And that illustrates the whole idea.
You will, and when you're doing
stuff you'll have obstacles.
But the magic comes in walking around the
obstacle and not letting it deter you, and
often you get to a much better solution
than you would if you didn't do that.
So it's important to
understand the difference.
And, again, I'm not voting on
any of the four, I'm saying just
know which state you want to be in and
don't confuse which one you are.
And you can go from one to the others,
no problem.
If I have to kill someone in order to do,
and it's against my moral principles,
I'm not going to do it,
I'm going to change my mind.
I'm going to stop, I'm going to try, or
I'm going to go have a pipe dream,
I don't care what.
You can go from one to the other,
just know which state you're
in is the important message.
Okay, so if you're really doing,
an obstacle doesn't stop you.
So I'd say awareness or
mindfulness is the key.
And the other things that could happen,
and I'm just going to close with this.
Language shapes the way we think, and
it's important to worry
about what language you use.
So for example, instead of using
the word but, if you use the word and
a lot more,
you'll find you'll have a better life.
Instead of saying you have to, if you say
you want to, you'll have a better life.
Instead of saying you can't,
you can say you will not.
And instead of saying help,
you can use the word assist, and so forth.
There's a whole bunch of words you can
use that make your life much better.
The words change the way you are,
and if you use the right words it will
make things go a lot better for you.
So I've kind of given you all
the wisdom I have at the moment,
and I want to thank you for
your attention.
And we're opening up now for
the second part of this session
where we'll have questions.
Thank you.
>> And now we'll head into our Q&A
session and we'll take some
questions from our attendees.
So Bernie, our first question is, how can
you convince your management to rephrase
a problem without giving reasons?
>> Well usually
it's a matter of doing,
rather than giving reasons.
And I had an experience where
three people from a company,
I probably shouldn't name it,
came and did one of our workshops.
And they went back and had an idea,
and the manager said I'm sorry,
we have no room to do this, and all that.
And he gave them all sorts of
reasons why they couldn't do it.
And they said well, they caucused and
they said well, let's do it,
not let's try to do it.
And they set up a space in the hallway,
he wouldn't give them an office,
they set up a space in the hallway and
they eventually did it and they went on.
So it's just a matter of, it's a good
reason that the manager doesn't
want you to do it,
really if you look in your heart.
There are lots of stories around.
I think Emerson's got the cell phones
because, which was a big hit for
them years ago, because this one guy
his boss said he couldn't do it so
he went home in the garage and
he made the first cell phone for Emerson.
So it really gets to that, it's really
it's a good reason the boss and
the dean and all that,
and if you want to do it
you are smart enough to find a way.
>> Great,
it's kind of like the old saying, where
there's a will, there's a way, right?
>> That's right, yeah.
>> Yeah, and so for our next question,
with regard to the lack of gender
diversity, and private equity, and
hedge funds, and unconscious gender
biases, how would you reframe the problem?
That problem in specific [LAUGH].
>> Well the question is,
what's the problem?
You're just telling me a social
situation which you don't like.
Is it how do I get more women in society?
You haven't really stated your problem,
you've stated a big issue.
So first of all, the best thing would be
to just take one person, like yourself or
whoever you want, and just like I did
with the woman with the money thing.
And just specifically say who it is,
what the issue is, and what
would happen if you could find a solution
without worrying about the solution, okay?
And then,
that would give you a way to work on it.
We don't have a problem yet to reframe.
But if you gave me a specific problem,
let's say,
let's make one up,
how do I get a higher salary?
So, I would say, what would it do for
you if you got a higher salary?
It might be, it will give me more
respect in the organization.
So the question is, how do I get more
respect in the organization rather
than the higher salary,
if it's not working.
I have nothing against you going for
a higher salary, hopefully you get it.
But that's what I'm saying.
If you take a specific question,
not a general world issue like
peace forever and stuff like that.
If you take a specific problem and
say that and you actually have attempted
to solve it, you give it attention and
it's not solving.
Then, it's time to reframe it, and
you reframe it by saying what
would the solution to that do for
me?
>> So on the topic of problem solving it
requires a great attitude and perspective,
how do we practice it every day?
What are some tips for
practicing every day?
>> Sure,
well you're practicing it
every day like it or not.
You're either doing a good job at it or
a bad job at it.
So I would say, the word mindfulness
which is a little overused is the answer.
It's a matter of not being oblivious but
looking at what you do, and
maybe going, I don't know if you
keep a diary or something like that.
But a good thing might be to go
when you go home at night or
in the morning if you
work on the night shift.
Write down what happened during the day in
terms of incidents and problems and what.
Analyze them, and say what you will
never do again, and what you did wrong.
So be aware of your behavior and see how
it goes ,and use that as a way to learn.
And you know we say failure's
a great way to learn.
So if you really do something bad,
you've learned,
make a, underline it in red and
don't do it again.
You'll do it again but eventually you'll
stop if you keep taking notice of it.
So I'd say awareness or
mindfulness is the key.
And don't go unconscious about
what's happening every day.
>> So I'd say awareness or
mindfulness is the key.
Shifting on to the next question.
Are there any ways to help yourself
move from the trying to doing stage?
Any ideas to find the motivation to
keep working even though there are many
obstacles in the way?
>> If you're not motivated, why bother?
[LAUGH] Many years ago, I was in Bulgaria,
and I heard this wonderful saying.
The Bulgarian saying,
there's no need to do anything.
And why is that?
If it's really important,
someone else will do it.
If it's not important, why bother?
[LAUGH] So
there's a lot of wisdom in that.
If it's not worth doing,
it's not worth doing well at all.
So just this whole idea that you have to
do, you have to do, you don't have to do.
You can have a great time just trying it.
But if you are motivated,
if you really want to do something, then
you can't let the obstacles block you.
My favorite story is my friend, Paul.
He was a swimmer, and
he had an accident in the shower, and he
had a back surgery and the surgeon said,
you can never swim competitively again.
But there was an Olympics coming up and
he wanted to go, and he talked to some
guy who was of a guru type and
he said, who can stop you?
If you want to do it, do it,
who cares what the doctor said?
So he trained fiercely,
there was not much time.
Trained fiercely in a local reservoir
here called Lexington Reservoir,
and he just qualified.
He was like the last person
to get onto the team.
It was between him and
someone, he just got on.
And he went to the Olympics and he won
a gold medal and he set a world record.
He came back, he put the medal on
the doctor's desk, and that was the point.
He had a good reason not to go.
The doctor said it won't happen.
But he was so motivated, and
he's been a serial entrepreneur.
He tells me every time he does something,
there's always a blockage.
There's always like the accident and
getting around is where the magic is.
But he has the motivation.
If you don't have the motivation,
forget about it.
Do something you feel motivated about.
>> So, last question here.
This is a quite specific question but what
is the approach or the right problem to
solve if you're disliking your current
job and want a new job opportunity,
how can you rephrase that problem?
>> I don't understand,
it seems like you have this problem,
it's all solved.
I don't know if there is
anything to rephrase.
If you don't like your job and
you want to get a new job opportunity,
I'd say that the question is how
do I get a new job opportunity?
And if you have any problems doing that,
say what would it do for me?
And if it's I'd have a happier life or
happy thing, maybe
you could stay where you are and reframe
what you're doing to make it happier.
You may have certain constraints that
aren't really there, and some people,
I have a friend who's
chronically unhappy and
every job he goes to he
has problems with it.
[LAUGH] So it doesn't matter if he changes
his job, now he has to change his being.
So it there's that whole aspect to it,
but if you're really in a job that's bad,
there's no hope and all that, then
clearly the answer is to change your job.
And you'll find lots of
reasons why you can't,
but they're all just good reasons.
>> Moral of the story,
there are a lot of good reasons.
[LAUGH] So thank you very much,
Bernie, for this awesome talk.
We're at the top of the hour now and
it's time to wrap up.
If you have any additional questions about
Stanford's professional programs on design
thinking and innovation, please don't
hesitate to reach out to us directly and
make sure to check your inbox for the
webinar recording within the next week.
Thank you again for
joining us today and hopefully,
we can see many of you with us
here on campus in September.